una calabacita fue pelada y cortada en
seis cubos idénticos cada cubo se pesó y
después se sumergió en una solución
sacarosa durante 24 horas en un
contenedor abierto con una temperatura
constante de 21 grados celsius los cubos
se quitaron de la solución se secaron
cuidadosamente con toallas de papel y se
volvieron a pesar se calculó el
porcentaje de cambio en la masa de cada
cubo debido a la ganancia o pérdida neta
de agua y los resultados se muestran en
la siguiente gráfica una línea recta se
incluye en la gráfica para ayudar a
estimar los resultados a partir de otras
concentraciones de sacarosa no probadas
usando la línea recta de la gráfica
calcula el potencial hídrico en bares de
la calabacita a 21 grados celsius
escribe tu respuesta con una cifra
decimal pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver lo que nos piden vamos a
resolverlo juntos tenemos 6 cubos de
calabacita y en la gráfica vemos que hay
6 puntos que corresponden a cada uno de
los cubos
por ejemplo este punto de arriba muestra
un cubo que se sumergió en una solución
que no contiene sacarosa
este cubo sumergido en una solución sin
sacarosa aumentó su masa un 20 por
ciento ese aumento de masa corresponde
al agua que fue absorbida por el cubo
podemos escribir esto diciendo que el
cubo que se sumergió en la solución sin
sacarosa tuvo una afluencia o ganancia
neta de agua lo suficientemente grande
como para aumentar su masa un 20 por
ciento ese segundo punto de la gráfica
corresponde a un cubo que se sumergió en
una solución de 0.2 moles de sacarosa
por litro y que también aumentó su masa
pero en este caso el aumento fue del 10%
o sea que fue un aumento pequeño así
continúa la gráfica hasta que llegamos a
este extremo de abajo donde el cubo de
calabacita se sumergió en una solución
con mucha sacarosa un molde sacarosa por
litro en este caso tenemos una salida o
pérdida de agua que ocasionó que el cubo
perdiera el 30 por ciento de su masa con
esta información como podemos calcular
el potencial hídrico de la calabacita
una forma de pensar en esto es encontrar
una solución de sacarosa en la que al
sumergir el cubo de calabacita éste no
tenga una ganancia o pérdida
agua esto indicaría que la calabacita y
la solución tienen el mismo potencial
hídrico esto lo podemos interpolar en la
gráfica si seguimos la recta pareciera
que si sumergimos un cubo de calabacita
en una solución de más o menos 0.36
moles de sacarosa por litro entonces el
cubo tendrá el mismo potencial hídrico
que la solución ya que no hay ganancia o
pérdida de agua así que el potencial
hídrico de la calabacita va a ser igual
al potencial hídrico de la solución de
sacarosa de 0.36 moles por litro así que
tenemos que encontrar el potencial
hídrico de esta solución la fórmula del
potencial hídrico como ya hemos visto en
otros vídeos es igual al potencial
soluto más el componente potencial de
presión sabemos que los cubos están
sumergidos en contenedores abiertos por
lo que el componente de presión es igual
a 0 así que solo necesitamos encontrar
el potencial absoluto de la solución de
sacarosa con esta concentración sabemos
que el potencial soluto es igual ai
negativa que es la constante de
ionización las moléculas de sacarosa se
disocian en el agua no
la sacarosa no se disocia en el agua por
lo que esto es igual a 1 esto se
multiplica por la molar y dad y se
multiplica por la constante de los gases
ideales también conocida como la
constante de presión y se multiplica por
la temperatura en grados kelvin todo
esto es igual a menos 1 porque ya
habíamos mencionado que esta y es igual
a 1 porque la sacarosa solo se queda en
el agua multiplicada por 0.36 moles por
litro x r y si ustedes resuelven esto en
un examen a p les van a proporcionar
esta fórmula y también el valor de r el
valor de r es 0.0 831 litros bares entre
mol por kelvin y se multiplica por la
temperatura en grados kelvin en el
enunciado nos dan la temperatura en
grados celsius por lo que sólo debemos
sumar 273 así que multiplicamos por 294
grados kelvin sacamos nuestra
calculadora y escribimos menos 1 por
0.36 por 0 punto 0 831 por 294 que es
igual a menos 8.795
pero como nos piden redondear a una
cifra decimal decimos que es menos 8.8
lo escribimos y las unidades son este
mal se cancela con este otro mol los
litros cancelan litros y este que el
bien cancela este otro kelvin por lo que
nos quedan menos 8.8 bares con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo